[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
sur le site de paris saclay consacré aux
mathématiques puisque vous savez
université de paris saclay été confirmée
par le classement de shanghai comme
numéro un au monde en matière de
mathématiques alors on va parler de
maths on va parler évidemment de ce
classement de cette distinction qui est
évidemment un accord formidable pour la
france
on va parler aussi bon de commande vient
mathématicien puis de qu'est-ce que
c'est peut-être les mathématiques
quels sont les enjeux de cette scion c
est pour en parler eh bien j'ai autour
de moi 4 4 grands mathématiciens pascal
mon cerveau jour êtes professeur à
l'université de paris saclay vous êtes
directeur de la fondation mathématiques
jacques à damart vous nous expliquerez
c'est que cette fondation
tout à l'heure à côté de vous frédéric
rossi bonjour bonjour vous êtes
professeur à l'université de paris
saclay vous êtes le directeur du
département de mathématiques d'orsay
d'ailleurs ici alors on est sur le site
de paris saclay mais on est hors séance
à sa wii donc on est à la faculté des
sciences d'orsay qui a une des
composantes de l'université paris saclay
et donc on est à l'institut de
mathématiques d'orsay dont qui est le
nouveau bâtiment qui regroupe tous les
mathématiciens d'orsay et qui a été une
grille abbas très longtemps en 2017 ça
oui c'est sa part emmanuel macron et
vous étiez là à côté de moi emmanuel
umoh bonjour vous êtes professeur à
l'université aussi de paris secte et et
directeur de l'i h
es alors on en parlera parce que c'est
très important dans l'histoire des
mathématiques aux mathématiques en
france à 10 h messe vous êtes
spécialiste je crois de géométrie
arithmétique se dire que vous savez tout
faire des allemandes il joue géométrie
l'arithmétique vous que moi je suis
arrivé aussi un total c'est pour ça que
je dis ça
tout colle aux imitations parfaites
robert et puis pierre poursuivront jour
bonjour patrice vous êtes professeur
d'université de brissac et vous êtes
directeur adjoint de la fondation
mathématiques
jacques à damas dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure vous êtes aussi alors j'ai vu
responsable de la vulgarisation pour le
laboratoire de mathématiques d'orsay
avait d'ailleurs été reçue pour ça le
prix charpak de la cabine et de
l'académie des sciences je me suis
réveillé une dérive et de poursuivre
oui c'est vrai un peu c'est que la
dérive et de prostituées écouter des
élèves de première et entendent parler
de dérive et pour la première fois une
vitesse par exemple c'est la dérive et
d'une quantité qui exprimait à quelle
distance
quelle distance on a parcouru en
fonction du temps mais on peut parler de
dérive et dans des contextes un peu
différent lié à la fois la géométrie aux
équations aux dérivées partielles mais
ça c'est là c'est la fin du xxème siècle
et une prometteur pour le 21e siècle
et quant à la vulgarisation c'est aussi
peut on va en reparler un tout à perdre
et c'est aussi peut-être l'idée bien que
les les les scientifiques vous êtes les
mathématiciens que vous êtes sortent
aussi un peu de l'elaboratoire faire
face connaît essaye de faire connaître à
un plus grand public les les interroge
donc ça fait partie de nos missions
de toute façon le contribuable droit de
savoir ce qui se passe dans les
laboratoires et puis nous avons besoin
nous mêmes nous ressentons le besoin de
faire connaître notre à vous parce que
nous en sommes fiers et je crois aussi
que c'est instructif pour eux pour le
public de partager notre vision de
l'avenir
puis enfin il faut aussi convaincre
des jeunes de se lancer dans les études
scientifiques qui ces tentes et des
aventures des mathématiques pour parler
justement sera aussi pourquoi vous même
vous avez été tentés par cette aventure
et des mathématiques mais on va
compenser par le premier de cette
émission sert paris saclay numéro un au
monde
[Musique]
alors d'abord ce que tu as beau alors
c'est pas il faut dire c'est pas la
première fois que vous êtes confirmé
je veux dire à ceux cette première place
aux côtes quand on sait qu'il va y avoir
ce classement de shanghai à vous êtes un
peu anxieux ou vous étiez sûr de vous on
prend du tout alors là absolument pas on
est parfaitement serein d'abord parce
que on n'a pas vraiment besoin que des
gens depuis shanghai décide de nous
placer à un endroit ou un autre c'est
disons que notre réputation à
l'intérieur de la communauté
mathématique est un petit peu au-delà
elle est établie depuis plusieurs
décennies et donc c'est donc comme vous
le disiez c'est une confirmation d'une
primauté qui est déjà bien établie dans
vous avez raison de dire que
probablement vous en tant que vous savez
ce qui se passe mais c'est vrai que aux
yeux de l'extérieur au dieu d'aider des
français aux yeux
peut-être dû du goût faire de beaux
enfants aux yeux de tous ceux qui vous
regardent
on voit quand même que le monde entier
regarde or c'est quoi c'est quand même
ça vous avez tout à fait raison et c'est
exactement la vertu positive pour nous
d'un tel classement c'est que il nous
permet d'être connue d'un public plus
large et en particulier de d'étudiants
internationaux qui se demandent où est
ce qu'ils vont poursuivre leurs études
s'ils ont été brillants dans leur pays
il n'y a pas nécessairement des
possibilités de poursuite d'études chez
eux donc et regardent et regard d'un
classement et
ils sont peut-être qu'ils ont envie de
venir à paris secte et d'ailleurs je
crois que la fondation mathématiques
jacques ada marra pu mesurer d'aidé de
l'année dernière l'impact de ce
classement ce dimanche donc la fin des
sciences politiques jacques ada marra
c'est une entité qu'il existe depuis
2000 ans c'est à dire que c'est une de
sin frontera pardon alors donc c'est un
mathématicien célèbre et qui comme
particularité d'avoir touché à beaucoup
de branche des mathématiques et comme la
fondation mathématiques jacques ada noir
se voulait très agnostique dans son
approche de la mathématique qu'il
souhaitait promouvoir et bien c'était
assez finalement confortable de
s'abriter derrière un nom illustre qui
lui-même a poussé a eu des résultats
dans toutes les branches les
mathématiques
donc cette fondation en un certain sens
elle a fédéré les mathématiques sur ce
vaste périmètre de parier sacré avant
même que l'université paris saclay ne
soient créés en un certain sens on a
demandé aux mathématiciens de prendre un
peu les devants et de mettre en avant
d'aider à la fois des actions en termes
de formation et de recherche qui
permettent aux mathématiciens de
l'ensemble du périmètre de travailler
ensemble
et parmi ces actions là il ya donc un
programme de bourses qui s'appelle le
programme se figea main et qui s'adresse
à des étudiants de masters
internationaux et on a constaté cette
année en effet comme le disait pierre
qu' il ya eu un nombre de candidatures
bien plus élevé que les années
précédentes le double de candidature et
avec non seulement beaucoup plus de
candidatures mais des créatures de très
grande qualité et donc ça effectivement
les classements internationaux ont des
parents anxieux parce que c'est
peut-être pas dans notre nature d'être
anxieux mais en tout cas on est quand
même assez fier il faut bien y briller
alors on est assez fiers vivante et
surtout on est fiers pour notre
université et aussi pour les efforts que
notre présidente d'université a fait
pour que ce programme
ce projet existe donc c'est quand même
une consécration pour le projet
d'université paris saclay parce que
évidemment que les mathématiques du
périmètre sont très bonne qualité depuis
longtemps comme le disait pierre mais ça
ne se voyait pas l'outil paris saclay
permet que tout d'un coup ça devienne
visible mais ça on le savait ça se
voyait pas ça des gens ne le savaient
pas les gens de la communauté ne savez
les gens de la communauté de sabella sûr
mais quand vous dites alors que vous
avez beaucoup de candidatures
internationales se bat tous les beaucoup
de très bons chercheurs je pense dans le
monde entier rêvent de venir à paris sac
n'est pas ça qui se passe ça veut dire
que l'ansej
est ce que l'enseignement pas que vous
êtes tous ce professeur d'université est
ce que l'on sait du mans peut s'ouvrir
aussi à des gens de deux de nationalité
étrangère
alors ça c'est une des merveilles de
mathématiques c'est que c'est un langage
universel c'est à dire que même si même
si les jeunes arrivent avec un niveau de
français ou d'anglais qui est un peu
hésitant ce qui est parfois le cas de
nos étudiants asiatiques
très rapidement il se met au diapason
parce que simplement le langage formel
des mathématiques leur permet de
comprendre un cours de mathématiques
peut-être plus facilement qu'un un cours
de littérature française d'accord donc
ça c'est un aspect des choses par
ailleurs il ya une grande solidarité
parmi les communautés d'étudiants
étrangers il ya une espèce de diaspora
qui se forment et que nous nous
encourageons au travers de systèmes de
tutorat ouvre incite les jeunes à être
solidaires et à s'occuper de la
génération suivante donc des
conséquences et cet cette ouverture au
monde évidemment sur les raisons au fond
parce que les réseaux de l'excellence
française vous avez raison de dire le
travail qui a été fait ici elles sont
assez peut-être assez ancien justement
je voulais qu'on parle de 2 de l'ios
avec vous et manuel ullmo parce que
c'est vrai qu'à bien compris dans les
années 50 et de grands mathématiciens
qu'il est homogène et rodez tome qui
vous créiez hs c'est ce à quoi cet
institut industrielle qui
à la vision qu'il faut créer un institut
où les gens peuvent faire de la
recherche totalement désintéressé et un
centre d'accueil pour les mathématiciens
du monde entier
donc il a en tête le modèle de
l'institut france vendredi à princeton
et
commence à créer cet institut en pensant
que ça ferait essentiellement un tour de
table industriels qui ne financeraient
est au tout début ça se passe un peu
comme ça mais après il se rend compte
qu'il a aussi besoin de l'état et c'est
en mode est un petit peu plus mixtes
donc il est en discussion avec
oppenheimer qui dirige l'institut
ponemon sbee à cette époque ne fait
venir d'un conseil scientifique
rangs des conseils très les statuts des
fesses et une embauche alexandre
grothendieck qui va devenez à des
mathématiciens le plus important de vue
du milieu du siècle dernier et qu'il a
fédéré sur le périmètre de paris-saclay
tout un ensemble de mathématiciens qui
vont venir derrière lui dans son
séminaire donc et en particulier tous
les géomètres ingénieristes qui vont
après se retrouver ici dans le
laboratoire d'orsay est donc dans tout
début d année à la fin des années 50
début des années 60 il ya une
convergence de mathématiciens
extraordinaire autour de voter ni pour
puis du ligne entre deux chaises et déjà
le département de mathématiques d'orsay
c'est pour ça que ça se situe ici en
fait c'est ça qui explique à potins donc
le laisser l'excel crec aux axonais oui
on est à 25 minutes à pied ou d'une
autre
donc ce après ce modèle a continué
il peut apporter des choses différentes
de ce que font les universités
traditionnelles que c'est une structure
d'accueil pour des mathématiciens du
monde entier à tous les ans reçoit 200
chercheurs du monde entier qu'il est
progressivement de recherche en moyenne
de 2 mois et demi donc on attire
beaucoup de bien les immensités du monde
sur ce périmètre
et puis on a un petit pôle d'excellence
avec des charges au plus haut niveau qui
ont reçu deux distinctions importantes
en particulier la médaille fields qui
est naissante de tu vas landry a novel
ya il ya quantité d'entités faut pas
exagérer mais il ya un nombre
impressionnant de france et de
mathématiciens français qui ont fait 7
bebye alors cela on me sens seulement il
depuis les etats unis
alors qu'on est moins nombreux que les
américains donc sur le périmètre d'une
main de maître une pierre de ligne alun
comme jean bourgain maxime constant
comme s'est vite jean christophe you
cause ou linéaires meurent avant tout un
scénario presque de sa professeur de
jazz ka professeurs
certains disent est vrai serveur
québécois qu'on a entendu oui on est
très très fort en mathématiques
peut-être moins un peu moins dans les
autre chose parce que ça coûte rien dire
que si on a un stylo et une feuille de
papier peut-être un mathématicien
il n'y a pas besoin d'équipement etc
sont des mairies comme l'enseignement
supérieur en france est plutôt par un
parent pauvre évidemment les
mathématiques qui ne demande pas des
investissements formidable on a des on a
des cerveaux formidable mais voilà qui
ont pas besoin de matériels énormes
certains arguments si patrice c'est un
raisonnement qui est intéressant mais si
on le poussait jusqu'au bout on
conclurait que dans tous les pays
pauvres du monde
il va surgir une école maternelle
c'est pas ça se passe pas exactement
comme ça c'est vrai vous avez juste à
bout d'arguments c'est plus est plus
complexe
il ya effectivement il ya une alchimie
assez particulière spécifique à la
france à l'ile-de-france et à ce
périmètre
5 les mathématiques sont sont fortes en
france dans son ensemble il ya une chose
tout à fait remarquable c'est qu'on
trouve des mathématiciens des groupes
des mathématiciens de très très bon
niveau pratiquement dans tous les coins
de france enfin dans les 54 unités
mixtes de recherche du cnrs et dans 54
universités différentes et c'est sur ce
see as il ya ce terreau qui est bien
répartie sur le territoire qui je pense
que c'est un facteur mais il ya d'autres
facteurs
peut-être passé d'après des riverains
directeur d'un laboratoire et que des
patrons de mathématiques oui c'est donc
le le disons que le lien entre
l'enseignement et la recherche
s'organisent différemment dans forcément
différemment pour les mathématiques et
on a effectivement possibilité de
d'initier les étudiants à la recherche
de manière probablement plus facile que
dans les sciences expérimentales
donc c'était un peu l'idée de la
conception du bâtiment ici le don qu'il
ya le ce bâtiment abrite à la fois le
laboratoire de mathématiques d'orsay
donc les chercheurs professionnels et
les enseignants chercheurs
professionnels et il ya aussi des cours
à partir de des cours de maths à partir
du niveau duel 3 donc de la troisième
année de licence pour pour faciliter des
échanges entre entre étudiants et
chercheurs
donc le je pense que la tradition
d'essayer d'attirer les étudiants
les étudiants vers la recherche est
quand même et quand même ça qui permet
aussi de préparer la formation de
beaucoup de mathématiciens de très haut
niveau
université de paris saclay ou au
département de l'aude or c'est alors
j'ai pas kaka quel niveau mais les
étudiants ils sont sélectionnés vont
entrer jeudi a fait très fort en maths
pour arriver dans l'adversité de paris
saclay par exemple nous patrice d'un
vous vous nous mettez sur un sujet qui
nous intéresse puisque justement faire
venir des jeunes étudiants les plus
brillants possible ça fait partie de nos
soucis mais d'un autre côté l'université
paris saclay à une obligation de service
public
elle est ouverte à tous les lycéens de
qui s'intéressent aux sciences dans un
périmètre géographique très large et
d'ailleurs pour faciliter cette à la
fois la fin du cursus des uns et des
autres une grande diversité de profils
de lycéens et d'étudiants d'universités
paris saclay a tenté une expérience
originale je crois qu'elle est unique en
france
ces filières de licence donc les
premières années après le bac existe
sous deux volets il ya une école
universitaire de premier cycle qui
accueille tous les étudiants qui
nécessite donc qui pense qu'il va leur
falloir un peu plus de temps pour pour
gravir les échelons mais qui vont y
arriver
d'une part et d'autre part elle a
quelques filières sélectives qui sont
souvent des doubles diplômes avec deux
majeurs de deux disciplines différentes
et qui nous permettent de faire avancer
plus vite des étudiants qui avaient déjà
un fort potentiel ou lycées qui sont
suffisamment sûrs d'eux et ces jeunes
gens on peut les initier à la recherche
de la licence dans des unités de ils
font des projets de recherche ça
commence
en première année de licence ça continue
en 2ème 3ème année et nous espérons
comme ça les attirer jusqu'à un doctorat
qui est le diplôme de référence en
mathématiques pour tous les métiers des
mathématiques parce que est ce que
justement est ce que il ya comment ça se
passe parce que y'a rien une chose assez
assez qui peut paraître comme ça c'est
étrange
paris paris saclay bon première
université au monde quand on compte
quelques classements pisa sur les élèves
au lycée on voit le niveau en maths est
en train de baisser
partout est ce que est ce que ça vous
préoccupe ou est-ce que ça vous dit
après tout les gens qui sont au niveau
qui sont qu'elle vous trouve voilà c'est
plutôt des exceptions donc ça n'a pas
d'importance je vais essayer de vous
répondre non pas que le directoire de la
fondation est un petit jack adam armée
comme un statisticien parce que par
ailleurs moi je suis tel simple de
métiers de spécialités plus tôt donc
c'est pas parce que l'on constate que le
niveau baisse en moyenne ce qui est on
va dire que c'est confirmé par certaines
études que ça veut pas dire que les
extrêmes restent ne sont pas un niveau
d'excellence et donc il ya une
contradiction apparente entre
effectivement ce niveau qui baisse en
moyenne et puis nous qui vous disent on
met les jeunes qu'on a on a l'impression
qu'ils sont de plus en plus forte
donc les l'était ce qui se passe en
mathématiques ici sur ce périmètre sont
d'une un niveau qui est exceptionnel et
donc une apparente contradiction mais
c'est juste que à leur niveau
d'excellence les jeunes mathématiciens
français restent extrêmement compétitif
ce qui ne veut pas dire que ce soit
contradictoire avec le niveau qui baisse
en moyenne donc ça nous inquiète un peu
quand même bien sûr mais comme
l'enseignement secondaire j'ai pas vous
moi j'ai six enfants et quatre
petits-enfants donc ça m'inquiète mais
disons qu'un autre niveau on peut pas y
faire grand chose d'autre que d'essayer
de faire un autre échelle à nous ce
qu'on peut faire c'est à dire on fait de
la formation aussi des professeurs de
de deux collèges et puis de lycée ça
fait partie de nos missions
donc on essaie de le faire le mieux
possible et vous êtes aussi des
enseignants tous absolument en
mathématiques plus encore qu'ailleurs
c'est ce que soulignait frédéric la
recherche est vraiment adossé à la
formation ou la formation est aussi
adossé à la recherche d'ailleurs elles
vont de pair et l envie et la volonté de
transmettre va avec le fait de produire
de nouvelles de connaissances enfin
produire de nouvelles connaissances
donne envie de transmettre aussi bien
donc ça il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas
de souci là-dessus par contre on n'a pas
de prise directe sur ce qui se passe
dans le lycée on a une prise indirects
marionnaud la qualité de la formation
des maîtres qu'on peut produire mais
c'est c'est une effet indirect mais oui
on est bien sûr que ça nous suffit aussi
la question qui suit celle là justement
après ce qu'on appelle la baisse de
niveau 2 secondes et vous avez assez
d'étudiants il ya ainsi d'étudiants en
france grâce au général en mathématiques
je pense qu'on pourra en accueillir
davantage j'en ai on a une crise des
vocations ça on peut vraiment on ne peut
pas le nier même si depuis que le marché
de de la formation et c'est devenu plus
mieux organisés par admission post bac
et puis parcours sup les grandes
universités comme la nôtre on ont
bénéficié ont vu leur nombre de
candidatures augmenté on n'y a de toute
façon on est très en dessous des 2
l'attractivité qu'on avait auprès des
lycéens français dans les années 90 par
exemple donc là il ya un gros travail à
faire pour pour donner l'envié aux
lycéens de se lancer dans des études
scientifiques et c'est un terrain sur
lequel l'université paris saclay est
très active et notamment ce laboratoire
on va dans les lycées on va dans les
collèges on épaules
on encourage les professeurs du de ces
établissements qui souvent sont des
anciens étudiants de chez nous et on
essaie de faire passer un peu de de
notre goût pour les mathématiques
un peu de notre passion est-ce que je te
projet j'ai vu que dans les thèses
bazoum que vous avez
d'étudiants très haut niveau que vous
avez eues il y en a qui se consacre à la
recherche puis y en a qui sont partis
dans l'industrie par exemple je me
trompe non il me semble que j'ai vu qu
avez vous avez un étudiant en fait c'est
pas vraiment dans l'industrie il est y
travaillent dans un idée il fait du il
est consultant dans un cabinet juridique
de dans l'ain dans un service de brevets
en fait donc il donne un avis
scientifique sur les deux sur les
demandes de brevets qui sont déposées ok
ok pour b est ce que je voulais prouver
par là est ce que quand je me brosse
voilà peut-être qu'il ya des gens qui
regardent et qui se disent je fais
peut-être si je mon match peut-être bien
des licences de match puis peut-être un
peu plus mais est ce que le débouché
ckoi par l'enseignement la recherche est
ce qu'il ya des débouchés dans
l'industrie dont oui le doctorat c'est
ce qu'on veut faire le jeu au pied qui
veut à laizy des débouchés dans la tête
c'est à dire que il ya d'abord de
nombreux débouchés qui se situe dans
comment dire à bac +5 et dans des dans
des secteurs de des mathématiques qui
sont 17h10 de mathématiques appliquées
notamment tout ce qui touche au contact
des mathématiques avec l'intelligence
artificielle ça donne évidemment
énormément de d'emplois pour des jeunes
qui ont fait des maths mais aussi la
recherche elle-même n'est pas purement
orienté de manière académique c'est à
dire que un doctorat c'est aujourd'hui
une porte d'entrée au niveau
international
une porte d'entrée extrêmement
importante sur le marché des emplois de
haut niveau dans les entreprises au
niveau international c'est extrêmement
vrai en france
ça l'est un tout petit peu moins mais
les choses changent et aujourd'hui on
constate que le niveau de recrutement
n'est plus comme par le passé le niveau
ingénieur et un dd
une des raisons d'être entre guillemets
du modèle d'université qui défendu ici
qui intègre des grandes écoles en même
temps que des départements
universitaires c'est aussi de permettre
aux ingénieurs ainsi qu'aux étudiants
qui passent par des centres
universitaires comme celui danser et
bien d'accéder au doctorat et d'avoir
une formation de très haut niveau et
avec des valeurs scientifiques
importantes et salé valeur scientifique
c'est quelque chose qui est valorisable
en tant que tel c'est à dire que on peut
penser qu'un doctorat peut être utile à
ça à ceci ou à cela un doctorat de
mathématiques de mathématiques
appliquées peut faire avancer des
problèmes de nature industrielle
mais même un doctorat de mathématiques
fondamentales et formateur en tant que
tel quand on est en train de réfléchir
seul à surmonter des problèmes ça ce
sont des qualités qui sont aussi
valorisables au niveau de l'entreprise
quand on a un rapport à la vérité
scientifique qui est à un rapport
éthique
les choses sont vraies ou elles sont
fausses on fait des hypothèses on arrive
à une conclusion
eh bien ça donne des gens qui dans
l'entreprise on s'en doute une façon
d'aborder des problèmes qui va être un
petit peu différente de ceux qui ont une
formation un petit peu différente donc
ça donne de la richesse dans la
formation des gens qui vont vers les
entreprises et la diversité enseignant
en biologie quand même c'est assez
favorable et à sévir et et justement on
parle de ce classement tsonga qui fait
que voilà
monde entier regarde la télé les
entreprises aussi vous vous regardez
héros des contacts avec vous alors les
entreprises ont bien sûr des contacts
avec les laboratoires du périmètre
depuis depuis des lustres la recherche
ça peut les intéresser
bien entendu et donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui est qui est en place et de est
depuis longtemps ce qu'on essaie de
mettre en place maintenant c'est
vraiment des ponts qui permettent à des
doctorants qui ont fait des doctorats
non pas en entreprise par des convention
cifre parce que ça tu en as certain sens
pour eux les choses sont gagnées
d'avancé c'est à dire que ils ont fait
un doctorat au sein d'une entreprise en
relation avec laboratoire ça on sait
faire ça marche très bien
vous continuez à le faire mais c'est une
façon de procéder il ya aussi une autre
façon de procéder qui est celle qui
prévaut le plus souvent à l'étranger
c'est à dire vous avez des doctorants
qu'il faut un doctorat en milieu
académique et qui ensuite fond le
passage père l'entreprise et ça en
france c'est quelque chose qui se fait
mais pas encore de manière complètement
évidente
par exemple un peu plus la fondation
mathématiques jacques à dhamar que je
dirige a comme objectif de permettre de
créer des points de passage et des
outils qu'on met en place justement en
s'appuyant sur le savoir-faire de nos
grandes écoles qui sont sur le périmètre
pour arriver à créer cette cet amour ce
désir mutuel entre la formation
académique basé sur la recherche de haut
niveau qui est le doctorat et puis
l'entreprise
j'ai lui vous allez dire si c'est vrai
ou pas vrai dire que l'une des raisons
peut être qu'ils expliquent l'excellence
mathématiques françaises dont notamment
de renault ce territoire c'est des
particularités dans la gestion et
l'évolution de carrière par exemple j'ai
quelques pas qu'on peut pas rester plus
de 5 6 ans dans le même poste au cnrs
c'est vrai ça c'est pas tout à fait vrai
disons que les mathématiciens ont choisi
de s'organiser
d'une certaine manière ou par rapport à
d'autres disciplines
il y a peu de chercheurs cnrs et il y a
plus de chercheurs jeunes donc haut
niveau chargé de recherche que deux
directeurs de recherche pendant tout un
temps les débuts de carrière des gens
les plus brillants se faisait au cnrs et
après cinq ou six ans il devenait
professeur d'université
non la plus grand partie de la recherche
se fait par des professeurs d'université
avec quelques directeurs de recherche
qui sont en nombre petits moules de
training d'éventuels autres éventualités
et donc ça ça a été un aspect et un
aspect que la communauté mathématique a
imposé à ses scrupuleusement cellules
non recrutement local donc de demander
toujours que quelqu'un qui a fait une
tête en laboratoire trouve un
laboratoire d'accueil dans une
université autre que quelqu'un qui est
maître de conférences ou chargés de
recherche dans un laboratoire passe
professeurs ou directeurs de recherche
dans un autre laboratoire et on a
systématiquement fait ce type de choix
qui change beaucoup l'ambiance dans
l'événement un toit parce que il n'ya
pas qu'en quand des jeunes collègues
discutent avec des collègues plus âgés
il n'y a pas la question de savoir si on
va aller pour vous voir c'est une chose
et quand la réciprocité existe ce n'est
pas un problème pour les gens ça peut
l'être non nous aurons des zones aspect
plus petit ou
un âge où c'est plus compliqué c'est
long de 2009 et sa sagesse et
l'expérience sur la région parisienne
il n'y a pas de vraie raison que de
garder ses while si on se laissait
change et ça a été le contraire ific
pour les uns pour les autres bon ça je
pense que la communauté mathématique a
réussi à se mettre des critères
d'excellence dans ses recrutements
elle a fait des choix de se tourner vers
l'international de ne pas penser que
localement est là elle a réussi à
travailler ensemble en particulier ici
avec un continuum de mathématiques de
mathématiques dites fondamentales mettre
une équipe n'est plus appliquée et cette
loi était très important pour une
institution comme la nôtre de penser
qu'il ya une totale unité dans les
mathématiques et il n'y a pas d'un côté
la recherche fondamentale et d'autre
part sa guise évidemment mais le
département de mathématiques d'orsay a
toujours été quelque chose on écrivait
mathématiques sans s et on voulait
signalé par là qu'il avait qu'une seule
la connectique elle va et quand il n'y
aurait pas à côté de nobles d'un côté
puis un côté plus mercantiles de l'autre
barrage absolument pas et le quantifier
les mathématiques très fondamentale
utilisent en permanence
de mathématiques que l'appliquer aurait
intérêt à se lancer dès d'autant plus le
il ya des gens qui sont classés dans des
mathématiques appliquées qui font des
choses effroyablement théorique
enfin le tout c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué qu'on pourrait continuer de
penser là
et donc voilà on tient on tenait cette
diversité quoi je tiens cette unicité
des thématiques là-bas thématiques
je pense que le laboratoire de
mathématiques d'or fait énormément de
succès parce qu'il a su travailler
ensemble parce qu'on appelle
mathématiques fondamentales et
appliquées et c'est une d'ailleurs si
quelqu'un vous devez vous demander
on aimerait bien aussi nous avoir les
même palmarès que les diversités de
paris saclay si vous vous demandez vous
les réseaux de de vos rêves de votre
réussite vous diriez quoi
alors moi je suis pêcheur à la ligne
jeux pêche la truite
quand on me demande où sont les bons
coins de pêche jean valjean mais si
c'est bien sûr j'en ai dit j indique de
traitement mais pas les meilleures
regardez vous nous permettrait de rester
discret sur la question
en fait en vrai si vous voulez il ya
quand même une réponse qu il ya quand
même une réponse est à dire qu'il ya
quand même eu des idées de départ qui
étaient des idées saines c'est à dire
promouvoir l'excellence l'ouverture vers
l'international ce sont des idées saines
elles ont été promus dans une double
étoiles qui est 10h messe d'une part et
le département de mathématiques d'orsay
d'autre part donc un contexte d'
institut qui accueillait donc des
personnalités étrangères de grand renom
et un contexte de départements de
formation et de recherche
ici le département de mathématiques
d'orsay et en un certain sens les clés
historique du succès sont là ces doubles
étoiles qui à fonctionner en symbiose
avec des échanges scientifiques très
profond avec des gens qui ont été très
influencé par des sommités qui était qui
passait à 10 h messe il ya des des
professeurs illustre de ce département
qui historiquement ont été des élèves au
moins spirituel
gens qui passaient ali hs et donc il ya
eu toute cette influence la qui était
extrêmement importante et aussi la mise
en place ici dans ce département de
médecine dans ces deux modes de
recrutement qui était à peu près unique
en france éveillant vous effectivement
on faisait une recherche prospective des
meilleures recrues possibles et ça
longtemps à l avance et avec une
réflexion profonde et ensuite des
propositions faites aux gens qui étaient
recrutés et donc les professeurs
d'université ici ont toujours été
recruté avec un soin extrême et sa
partie ça participe aux raisons disons
maintenant c'est pas parce que vous avez
le forez bien soigné avec des chaînes
avec des châtaigniers qui aura des
truffes intrusion nature n'en voulait
dire qu'il ya un peu de hasard
j'ai eu la chance de vivre de manière
contemporaine avec jean-christophe show
cause qui était un ami
on a joué au foot ensemble sur ici tient
juste en dessous parce qu'ici c'était un
terrain de foot dans les temps
ancestraux
donc on a patiné dans la boue la leçon
de l'yvette on à patauger dans la boue
avec jean-christophe jean-christophe je
les ai connus avant qu'il a aimée de
kylie la médaille fields c'était un
mathématicien évidemment remarquable un
compagnon
de jeu et un ami quelqu'un d'extrêmement
modeste il a eu la médaille fields super
ça aurait pu être quelqu'un d'autre
il faisait partie des gens qui étaient
susceptibles de l'avoir donc il ya une
partie de roulette
mais plus vous avez de gens brillants
qui se font partie du jeu et plus vous
avez des chances d'être successfull on a
parlé de 2,2 de l'institut d'amapa denis
a choisi ce serait alors quand on va sur
le site il ya aussi des neuf
laboratoires l'université de paris
saclay à la solliciter centre bourg et
dit l'institut de physique théorique
le laboratoire de mathématiques de
modélisation d'evry le laboratoire de
mathématiques d'orsay
le laboratoire de mathématiques de
versailles de mathématiques informatique
appliquée mathématiques et informatique
appliquée du génome à l'environnement
alors c'est quoi c'est quoi ces
laboratoires
moi j'ai une belle histoire à vous
raconter vous explique un peu comme ans
commença coopèrent et comment
sélectionne les mathématiques
donc évidemment on est de manière un peu
peut-être artificielle comme vu de
l'extérieur en train de travailler avec
les mathématiques de versailles donc
c'est quand même assez éloignés
géographiquement on peut pas dire que
cela porte à côté
mais comment ça commence sa commune tout
ça bien si vous prenez le programme de
langlands qui est un programme
mathématiques très abstrait qui est un
peu lent secteur de mathématiques de mon
ami là emmanuel umoh si vous voyez ci
mathématiques la très abstraite
il ya plein de gens qui travaillent sur
ces métiers sur ses mathématiques très
abstraite des gens de très haut niveau
et ça a produit deux médailles fields
ici laurent lafforgue d'un côté et puis
ngoc de l'autre
goba chaud ça vous allez me dire bcd
médiatique mais jamais de la vie et
jamais au monde ça n'aura d'applications
quoi c'est fait pour des athlètes de
haut niveau qui vont avoir effectivement
une menace les créations intellectuelles
alors on est très content d'avoir les
médaillés olympiques enfin une swatch
quoi mais c'est le cas ça me fait pas qu
aurait fallu huit mois exactement
eh bien en parallèle le fait que c'est
mathématique existe a permis de
développer
des méthodes de cryptographie qui
s'appuie sur et jamais tripes et à dick
et jamais de la ville jamais très
pudique n'aura existé s'il avait pas eu
ces gens oui c'est ça c'est qu'il ya un
gisement de connaissances qui se produit
et c'est les mathématiques c'est un
aller retour permanent entre des gens
qui comme moi sont à l'affût de ce qui
se passe au niveau des applications et
que les applications inspire pour
développer leurs recherches on les
appelle des mathématiciens appliquée et
des mathématiciens plus fondamentaux qui
ont une technique un petit peu
différente et qui développe un jugement
de connaissances qui peut être un jour
va servir et même sûrement un jour va
servir parce que pour faire de la
modélisation il faut qu'ils les modèles
et maintenant j'en arrive avec nos amis
de versailles
parce que figurez vous qu'à versailles
qu'est ce qui se passe on développe une
formation de haut niveau en
cryptographie et donc on utilise mêmes
matin pour former des jeunes d'accord
qu'ils vont trouver des emplois dans
quel secteur est bien la sécurité
informatique vous a entendu parler un
petit peu des questions a décidé jeudi
de plus en plus même
et voilà eh bien vous ne saviez pas que
les questions de prague aussi et je
devais un rapport quelconque avec le
programme de langlands et bien si je
rejoins ce que disait emmanuel c'est
dire que voilà ne faut pas de s ab
thématiques
c'est vrai que tu as tout de jeu c'est
de raconter la même histoire
[Rires]
l'afflux de milan les grèves ça
intéresse ou non premier qui existent
quand on essaie de comprendre ce que
c'est que les nombres entiers comment
les multiples
positionnement ça fascine ça peut faire
des progrès l'ensemble des mathématiques
parce que deux
iman qui est un nouveau point de vue
actuel importante
on comprend la distribution mon premier
alors personne n'aurait dit que savait
la moindre importance pour le mans grève
aujourd'hui l'ensemble de tous les
systèmes financières et sécurisées à des
codes qui sont juste la preuve la
multiplication de denon prenez un peu
grand et que c'est un peu compliqué de
savoir la risée factoriser et donc même
si on se pose des questions peut
vraiment pour la beauté de là il peut y
avoir un moment où on change
drastiquement de la fédération prl doit
faire tomber aujourd'hui il n'y aurait
pas eu connaissance de nombres premiers
mois le coup dessus de latran sévriens
thème s'écroule d'un seuil non c'est bah
voila c'est le risque pas de vous
servent les traits peinte en réalité
voilà finit pas avoir des applications
et les motivations que l'on a pour les
faire ou des parfums qu'ils ont pour la
beauté de l'art un jour s'avère être au
centre de ski et transforme alors on va
peut-être passer au 2e poids de
l'émission bbc commande vient
mathématicien pourquoi enlever le
mathématicien
c'est le deuxième thème de cette
émission là je vais commencer avec vous
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à vous parce
que vous étiez tous vous étiez tous
évidemment très très très très bon dans
le secondaire oui sarina d'abord ce qui
compte c'est qu'on aime ça je pense ce
raisonnement à l'abstraction le fait de
chercher et d'arrivée
d'arriver avec un truc complètement
logique arriver à un résultat donc le
bon jeu moi je viens pas d'une famille
particulièrement de mathématiciens donc
au début on s'aperçoit qu'on aime ça on
aimerait en faire plus et en fait après
on s'aperçoit qu'on peut tout à fait
faire ça professionnellement et donc
dans ce cas là c'est la joie de faire ça
et pascal pardon vois mon histoire avec
les mathématiques elle a démarré dans un
grenier en fait je faisais des j'ai donc
je vais je viens d'une famille très
nombreuse d'une petite cité ouvrière et
souvent je m'isolais dans le grenier
pour faire quoi pour faire des exercices
de maths alors pourquoi je faisais ça ça
je n'en sais strictement rien à dire
c'était c'était quelque chose qui m'est
que j'avais en moi et je faisais ça puis
je décide et des cartes de géographie à
main levée pourquoi je faisais ça je
n'en sais fichtrement rien j'avais envie
de faire ça voilà donc je passais mon
temps entre ce type de choses là et puis
allez allez à la pêche aller cueillir
des champignons et un jour j'ai réalisé
alors jetez pas trop mauvais à l'école
et puis un jour j'ai réalisé que faire
des maths c'était possible et puis j'ai
eu la chance d'avoir un menteur
absolument délicieux qui était quelqu'un
qui connaissait très bien et champignons
et donc on s'est très bien entendu grâce
à emmanuel enfin bon moi je pense que
vous avez profité d'une situation donc
quand j'étais
enfant je prenais du plaisir en tant que
des mathématiques à l'école et donc été
assez attentif hasard et j'avais des
facilités et donc en réussissant en
maths l'école grand v les messages que
l'état bonne élève donc ça me met galéré
liste de tout le reste est donc pendant
tout un temps vous voyez ces facilités
en masse le match passait bien et on ne
demandait pas trop pour le vasco mais à
la fin on se rend compte que les mac
qu'on peut faire donc ça m'a semblé
évident qu'il n'y avait pas autre chose
que des maîtres défi de fait nous sommes
rendu compte que je vais encore du
plaisir plusieurs zones plus élevées en
faire un moment des ondes vous nous
donner un salaire pour continuer à
arriver bien perçu moi mon histoire
ressemble à celle d'emmanuel quand
j'étais au collège je crois que je
m'intéressais plus tôt à l'archéologie
des et puis en troisième j'ai eu un prof
de maths dans une petite ville qui
s'appelle lons le saunier dans le jura
et qui s'était jusqu'à l'époque des
maths modernes je sais pas si vous avez
connu ça patrice tu peux même et cet
homme était elle était capable de nous
apprendre en mai simultanément les maths
modernes qui qui arrivait dans notre
programme mais aussi le le programme
anciens auxquels il avait un peu plus
confiance ils arriver à faire ça mais il
nous nous stimuler
et il me sourit j'ai un souvenir très
précis d'un jour où il lança un exercice
où une question à la classe et je suis
le seul à trouver la réponse et se
rendre compte que j'étais capable de
tirer quelque chose de ma tête ça c'est
toute conscience et après effectivement
je ne fais presque en dehors des matchs
et époque des faits vous n'avez pas
hésité chaque les uns les autres ou pas
avec la physique
sinon c'est trop dur et est ce que comme
un coq bien il ya eu peut-être un
enseignant qui vous les uns les autres
guidon vous étaient tous le grenier
plutôt nancy enfin oui et non c'est à
dire que moi j'ai un souvenir ému de
de ce qu'on appelait un instituteur à
l'époque et qui qui m'a qui m'a fait
comprendre que je pouvais faire des
choses ça oui et donc ça j'en ai un
souvenir ému mais je pense quand on est
beaucoup à avoir comme ça quelques
enseignants référence est bon si un jour
quelqu'un me dit que j'ai les mêmes
valeurs que cet homme là bas je serai
content alors on va passer d'un
troisième voie là le mathématicien et
puis maintenant on va parler débattre
qu'est ce que c'est les mathématiques
[Musique]
justement ou dizzy sait trop que le
physique c'est trop compliqué alors on a
comme ça l'idée du doigt un clay
mathematics et c'est la science pure
quoi c'est la science pour la science
c'est vrai ou c'est une idée qu'on ne
continue un peu éloigné de sa si c'était
vrai c'est peut-être que ça nous
simplifierait la vie c'est à dire que
y'a m
on a on parle de plus en plus dans la
recherche des tic et pendant très
longtemps nous mathématicien nous sommes
sentis complètement à l'écart des ces
questions d'éthique on a décidé de le
gisti sont confrontés quotidiennement
ont l'impression que les mathématiciens
ils sont besoin de ça exactement
et bien malheureusement fanou ça me
rattraper à grande vitesse avec la bombe
atomique de l'histoire des sciences
aimez les petites bêtises il était un
peu épargné pourquoi ils sont moins bien
parce que on a été l'objet de consignes
de constater mais de plus en plus ces
dernières dessinée de cet effet
efficacité inexplicable des
mathématiques et leur impact de plus en
plus grand sur la vie quotidienne
on a beaucoup parlé dans les années 2000
de l'évolution du monde de la finance et
de la technicité de la théorie et de la
pratique bancaire et les mathématiciens
ont quelque part ont joué un rôle ils
ont quand même fourni des outils fournis
ce qu'on appelle des algorithmes qui ont
rendu possible la finance à très haute
vitesse et et puis voilà qu'en 2008 le
csld un krach boursier qui a eu des
conséquences très forte enfin qui aurait
dû des gens à la misère enfin qui a
entraîné même en france dans vraiment un
vrai retard quand la croissance de
l'économie
un impact très fort et on peut nous ce
que les mathématiciens son porte une
part de responsabilité
évidemment non évidemment c'est à dire
qu'il est plus difficile de se relâcher
dans la tour d'ivoire quoi comme c'est
seulement 60 autres gens qui ont mal
utiliser les outils mis à leur
disposition sur les mathématiques qui
les ont utilisées toujours en dehors des
des limites dans lesquelles les
mathématiciens des pour lesquels les
mathématiciens les avait introduite est
garanti et donc il ya une mauvaise
utilisation d'une d'un outil mais malgré
tout ça fait réfléchir
là je vous parle d'un décennie passée
c'est bien qu'ils ont la décennie
suivante dès 2010 on commençait à voir
arriver c'est mathématique liés au
traitement de grandes masses de données
et qui donne lieu à des activités une
activité économique comme la
recommandation quand vous
vous promener sur un site internet
commercial chaque clic que vous faites
est enregistrée et quelque part il ya un
algorithme souvent qui fonctionne
derrière et qui va produire des
recommandations devaient les voir sortir
des d'autres clients on se sont
intéressés à tel produit d'accord donc
là il ya énormément de mathématiques qui
sont cachés derrière et qui se sont
souhaité développer très récemment qu'on
peut pas arrêter la terrible efficacité
encore une fois ses dribbles et est ce
que c'est bon pour l'humanité bah on
peut quand même se poser des questions
on nous parle maintenant d'intelligence
artificielle par l'intelligence
artificielle pardon est ce que justement
ça ça va pas changer
même votre métier quoi c est ce que la
chine va pas aller plus vite que les
mathématiciens
alors il ya même c'est vous qui l'avez
vous personnellement mais ils ont que
fin nous caler les méthodes qui sont en
ce moment les considérer comme les plus
efficaces dans ce domaine là sont des
méthodes qui repose sur des modèles de
la thématique le dip learning ça repose
sur les réseaux de neurones profond les
réseaux nous tenons une profonde ça se
définit comme des modèles mathématiques
donc c'est sûr que on est on est mouillé
jusqu'au cou comme dirait bien
donc on ne peut pas se sentir
complètement innocent dans l'avancée
tout ça enfin pouvoir aussi de ça de
manière positive c'est à dire que les
attentes et d'aidé pour les
mathématiques ont une influence certaine
sur le sur le pib
il ya des études qui montrent qu' il ya
un impact certain des mathématiques
notamment au travers de la formation de
jeunes on revient sur cette histoire de
jeunes docteurs qui vont dans les
entreprises etc et donc il ya un impact
faut aussi de voir de manière positive
mais c'est certain qu'on est on est du
coup
pas dans notre petite bulle magnifique
j'en reviens pas question un peu basique
mais est ce que est ce que des bâtisses
vous êtes vous dit pas mais avec l
intelligence artificielle de on va plus
servir à rien que c'est une bonne
question
et c'est vrai que de notre activité est
plutôt celle de la région de l'abandon
de la génération qui nous suit vont être
affecté très fortement par l'arrivée de
nouveaux outils par exemple à quelque
chose qui qui nous pourrit l'existence
c'est la peur de se tromper
un mathématicien il est tenu de
démontrer une tout ce qu'il affirme
il veut pas affirmer et dont il publie
rédigerait de des démonstrations des
folles longue et complexe et il a peur
de se tromper à chaque ligne
eh bien on voit arriver maintenant des
outils qui s'appelle des assistants de
preuves qui nous permettent de rédiger
une démonstration de telle sorte
qu'elles puissent être vérifiées
automatiquement
c'est merveilleux je ne suis pas
absolument preneur d'un outil comme
celui là vous voyez même dans notre
pratique quotidienne
nous voyons arriver à une évolution très
forte d'adam dans le bon sens mais là
c'est moi je le vois même en sens
inverse c'est à dire que moi je n'ai pas
du tout peur du développement de tiges
ans artificiel je trouve même que ça ça
crée de nouvelles activités en
mathématiques il ya de nouveaux
matériaux des nouveaux modèles
mathématiques sans peur ou pas peur donc
oui je sers à rien comme dirait ma
vieille mère qui débute ce monde la peur
n'évite pas le danger
voilà mes donc ça d'une pas mais
même plus sérieusement il ya des
activités il ya des pans entiers de
mathématiques qui n'étaient pas
concernés pendant certains sens par des
applications de direct et qui
aujourd'hui le sont parce que justement
il ya des médecins des mathématiques
nouvelles qui sont au contact de la
légende artificielle qui se développe
donc ça c'est quand même un point qui
est extrêmement positif bien ça fait ça
donne du dynamisme à la discipline de
vie de questions vous posez vous êtes
vous êtes universitaires chercheurs on
voit aujourd'hui des gaffes a qui disent
beaucoup de gens qui ont les mêmes
formations que vous qui leur propose à
peu près 10 fois ou quinze fois ce que
vous gagnez c'est plutôt encourageant
c'est plutôt des espérances est ce que
est ce qu est ce que la diversité
les deux mon général vous vivez où il
devrait l'aider reconnaître ça crée un
problème assez évident soit comme
discipline en particulier il y à une
demande de la société que l'on forme des
gens pour faire de l'intelligence
artificielle
et le problème c'est que on ne peut pas
maintenir dans mon mec là des mythes les
meilleurs pour assurer cette formation
parce que je suis petit mot dans la fin
ils ont d'un point de vue intellectuel
des choses très intéressantes à faire
effectivement des salaires qui ne sont
pas comparables
cependant la société a réellement besoin
sous forme de plus en plus de plans dans
ces sujets et donc il est réellement
obligatoire nous d'avoir un lien entre
université et
entreprises pour que la formation soit
aussi assuré les violons fait le pain
avait dans ces entreprises et donc ça
c'est un système qui doit commencer à se
mettre en place
qui est pas intuitif naturel pour nous
d'être confronté à z cette réalité
j'avais il ya une recherche qui était
complète il ya une recherche qui est
extrêmement dynamique maintenant dans
les fameux gafa dingue et ils ont bien
compris que offrir de la liberté
académique c'était aussi intéressant
parce que c'est attractif pour les
jeunes chercheurs qui veulent attirer
donc il ya une réelle compétition il ya
un réel enjeu pour la recherche
académique que de garder en son sein
quelques quelques quelques jeunes qui
ont une très haute qualité dans ces
domaines là parce que sinon qu'est ce
qui va se passer ici toute la recherche
dans ces domaines la fille de l'un des
entreprises
le souci c'est que il ya plus
d'arbitrage possible c'est à dire que
veut un chercheur va donner c'est
explicite et ses résultats dans un dans
un congrès il représente à la fois son
domaine mais aussi une entreprise
donc le rapport à la vérité est faux
c'est ce qui fait que un vieux monsieur
que moi on vient de temps en temps me
chercher pour faire un arbitrage parce
que pourquoi moi je suis pas jeune ait
de rapport ni règle pas d'intérêt je
n'ai pas d'intérêt et donc je peux
donner un arbitrage qui est un arbitrage
objectif et ça cette capacité à délivrer
des arbitrages objectif ce rapport à la
vérité c'est très intimement lié aux
mathématiques merci et merci à tous les
cas j'avais jamais d'histoire gélules a
récemment qu'on verra qu enfin c'était
un étudiant qui était très fort en
mathématiques etc is it et autres là je
crois la poésie et là vous connaissez
cette histoire entre la poésie et les
mathématiques et puis finalement il dit
à son à son maître
finalement j'ai choisi la poésie il le
concert lui dit vous avez bien fait vous
ayez pas assez d'imagination pour les
maths
est ce que vous êtes des plus des
balises hâtive des scientifiques ou en
un mot parce qu'il faut qu'on se quitte
ab on est on est certainement les plus
littéraires des scientifiques et et en
un certain sens ce qu'ils ont
le tempérament d'artiste le plus affirmé
c'est à dire qu'il ya il ya quelque
chose qu'on se dit entre nous et qui est
compréhensible sans doute pour le public
mais cette démonstration est vraiment
élégante
qu'est ce qu'elle est belle oui il ya de
la beauté là on part on parle d'une
preuve de n'être génétique comme on
parle d'une femme on club c'est lui moi
merci dont il faut constituer des années
merci merci à tous les quatre et puis
voilà et puis alors évidemment vous vous
donne c'est parce que tout d'un gros
bras vous quoi pour tout ce que vous
faites et pour le rayonnement vous fait
avoir sur le territoire et la france
merci à tous les caprices
[Musique]